Back in the 1970s, when I was
involved in developing an early EMR,
the data collection
problem was already clear.
In fact, for the most part,
our physicians dictated notes that
were transcribed into the EMR.
I used to tell visitors that someday,
voice recognition would make this
far more efficient and accurate.
Has that day arrived?
To answer that question,
we'll look at M*Modal,
one of the most advanced medically
specific voice recognition technologies.
As shown here, it not only
translates voice to text, but
it recognizes clinical
concepts in that text and
can code them into ICD-9 or SNOMED.
Here, 346.9 is the ICD-9 code for
migraine headache.
62972009 is actually the SNOMED CT
code for an extraction,
showing that at least at the time this
slide was made, which was a number
of years ago, the system was not exactly
perfect, because there is actually
a better SNOMED CT code that is
specific to wisdom tooth extraction.